-Ich habe eine erste Frage. Vielleicht
kennst du sie. Wie ist die Lage,    Kills?
-Die Lage ist ganz gut. Im Moment sind
wir ja hier in… ist es Düsseldorf?
-Ja
-Ich weiß nie, wie man sowas ausspricht.
Ich muss meine Deutsch mal  trainieren.
-„Düsseldorf“ ist perfekt ausgesprochen.
-Das ist gut
-Es ist mit diesem „U-Umlaut“.
-Was ist das mit diesem kleinen Punkt?
-Das ist nur dazu da um nicht „U“ zu
sagen in Deutschland sondern „Ü“.
-„Ü“?
-Düsseldorf, Düsseldorf.
-Düsseldorf?
-Ja, genau. Und wir haben das mit
„a, Ä“, „Ü, u“ und „Ö, O“
-Oh mein Gott, das ist verrückt. Das ist
wie französisch…
-Ja, ein bisschen.
…, es gibt so viele Töne.
Also, ja. Wir sind hier gerade in
Düsseldorf.
-Ja.
-Und es werden 50-60 Tausend
Leute hier sein heute Nacht. Ich eröffne
heute das Konzert der Black-Eyed-Peas.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du es vielleicht
weißt, aber will.i.am gab mir einen
Plattenvertrag.
-Ja.
-Vor Jahren.
Deshalb ist es verrückt hier zu sein mit
meinem fertigen Album und einen
Top-Ten-Song zu haben und jetzt eröffne
ich die Show für Will und die
Black-Eyed-Peas hier. Es ist ein
wahrgewordener Traum.
-Also hast du einen persönlichen Kontakt
mit den Black-Eyed-Peas?
-Ja, natürlich. Weißt du, also wir trafen
uns in London vor ein paar Jahren und
wir starteten zusammen zu arbeiten und
es waren großartige Erfahrungen.
-Okay. Ich sah eine Webserie von dir und
sie hieß „Love, Kills XX“
-Ja.
-Was ist dein Hauptberuf? Du bist eine
Regisseurin, eine Sängerin, eine
Textschreiberin, eine Schauspielerin. Was
machst du? So viel.
-Ich fing an als Schauspielerin. Und ich
mochte es nicht, weil immer wieder ein
Charakter zu spielen und  Texte zu lesen.
Und ich wollte einfach nur Ich selbst sein,
ich wollte meinen eigenen Ausdruck
haben, ich wollte die sein, die die
Geschichte schreibt, ich wollte meine
Geschichte schreiben. Also ging ich nach
ein paar Jahren im Fernsehen zum Musik-
und Textschreiben für andere Leute und
dann entschied ich mich mein eigenes
Album zu machen und für mich selber
Musik machen bis jetzt, nehm ich an.
-Okay. Aber diese Webserie, wie ist sie mit
deiner Musik verbunden?
-Mit der Webserie, vermisste ich es mit
der Kamera zu sein. Ich wollte das
Visuelle kreieren, einen Rückblick
machen, unter der Kontrolle zu sein, nicht
nur mit der Message, nicht nur mit den
Geräuschen, aber unter der Kontrolle zu
sein, was die Leute sehen. Und Ich traf
einen unglaublichen Regisseur aus Paris,
der mir lehrte wie man einen Film leitet
und jetzt arbeiten wir zusammen an allen
meinen Projekten. Also kann ich
meine eigene Meinung darüber erfinden,
wer ich bin. Mit und ohne der Musik.
-Okay. Wer bist du?
-Ich bin Natalia Kills, baby.
-Was bedeutet dieses „Kills“? Weil diese
Webserie geht oft über Rache.
-Ja.
-Liebe verbunden mit Rache. Mit Hass,
vielleicht ein bisschen?
-Ja.
-Also, was ist deine Geschichte? Was
meinst du mit „Kills“?
-Nun, es ist lustig, dass du das sagst, da
Ich viel von meiner Meinung freigebe und
mein ganzes Album ist über meine
Lebenserfahrungen und alles, was ich
denke und alles, was ich fühle. Also
nehme ich an, dass ich viel über Rache
nachdenke und ich habe viel Frust in
meiner Musik. Aber wirklich, Natalia Kills,
„Kills“ bedeutet, wenn du es killst, wenn
du 100% von deiner Leidenschaft und
deiner Energie in etwas, was dich
definiert. Wir sagen in Englisch, weißt du,
„Du hast es gekillt“, also wir wollen
wirklich sagen „Kills“. Es ist eine
Beschreibung für meine Persönlichkeit.
-Okay.
-Weißt du, wenn jemand „kurz“ wäre,
würdest du ihn als „klein“ bezeichnen,
wennn jemand… Ich weiß nicht… wenn
jemand einen Spitznamen hat, bei
„Robert“ könnte es „Bobby“ oder „Bob“
sein. Es ist einfach nur ein Spitzname, der
beschreibt, wer ich bin.
-Und deine Perfektion.
-Mein Album heißt „Perfectionist“, da
ich es definitiv liebe mich durch meine eigene
Vision auszudrücken.
Ich glaube wir sind alle Perfektionisten.
Nicht nur ich, nicht nur all‘ die andren
24-jährigen Frauen da draußen, die die
perfekten Beziehungen, die perfekte
Karriere, die perfekten Haare und
Fingernägel wollen; Ich denke, dass wir
alle Perfektionisten sind, wir suchen alle
nach der besten Version von uns selber.
Mein Album „Perfectionist“ hat nichts
damit zu tun, perfekt zu sein, es perfekt
zu haben. Es realisiert, dass es nicht
existiert. Verstehst du? Nichts ist richtig.
Es ist die Frust davon und das einzige,
was du tun kannst ist es, deine eigene
Perfektion zu kreieren.
-Okay. Also du bist ein bisschen,
entschuldige mich, Lady Gaga aus
Großbritannien?
-Meinst du?
-Ich weiß nicht, es ist eine Frage.
-Was denkst du denn?
-Manchmal scheint es mir ein bisschen
danach.
-Sag mir, was denkst du?
-Ich denke ja.
-Welche Elemente von mir kommen dir
bekannt vor?
-Die Perfektion, deine Kleidung, vielleicht
deine Frisur.
-Sie hat nicht
diese Frisur.
-Nein, nein, nein. Nicht die Kopie, nicht
die Kopie. Eine andere Art, eine britische
Lady Gaga.
-Ja. Und sie ist nicht britisch.
-Nein, SIE ist nicht britisch. Du bist
britisch.
-Danke dir.
-Es ist ein Kompliment?
-Ja, natürlich. Ich mag… Ich liebe Lady
Gaga’s Haare im Moment. Es ist dieses
grünliche, bläuliche Haar. Sehr schön.
Und ich denke, dass jeder, der seine
eigenen Lieder schreibt und der sehr
leidenschaftlich darüber ist, was wir
machen, ich kann mich auf sie beziehen.
Ich denke, dass es großartig ist. Ich
denke, dass ich mich ziemlich aufregen
würde, mit jemanden verglichen zu
werden, auf die ich mich nicht beziehen
würde, oder die ich nicht respektiere.
Aber ich finde, dass dieser Vergleich sehr
toll ist.
-Okay. Vielen Dank, dass ich dir ein
Kompliment machen konnte.
-Danke dir.
Ich denke, dass ich mich so fühle mit
Lady Gaga verglichen zu werden, wie sie
sich fühlt mit Madonna verglichen zu
werden.
-Okay. Das ist fein, denke ich.
-Ja. Du vergleichst mit jemanden, der
all‘ seine Leidenschaft gibt und, den alle
lieben. Was ist besser als das?
-Okay. Ich wünsche dir eine sehr
erfolgreiche Karriere und ein sehr
erfolgreiches Konzert hier in Deutschland.
-Danke dir.
-Vielen Dank.
-Danke.
*wisch*